new polling from ipsos shows while one
in five canadians feel things are normal
now the same proportions say they're not
sure they'll ever be ready to live
without masks or vaccine mandates
but regardless of when people think the
new normal will arrive 64 percent of
canadians say they believe governments
are not doing enough to get us there
well we seem to be pretty ready
and that's that's what's being
communicated out of the research but you
know it really is interesting that
almost 20 percent one in five say to us
that they don't think they'll ever be
ready that we'll ever be going back to
normal so even though uh we're saying
that we want to get back to something
that resembles a normal life we're still
pretty tentative
while the thing that they're really
saying to us at the moment is they still
believe that there's a significant risk
out there particularly with the omicron
variation and uh so things like for
example vaccines remain very high on
people's list of uh list of necessities
they're also still prepared to uh to uh
take
certain restrictions in terms of their
own personal freedom like shutdowns and
that kind of thing if they think that
things got out of control so i would say
that where they are right now is on
fairly thin ice but they feel like the
ice is thickening up a bit but still not
enough to just kind of you know run out
there into the middle of the lake yeah
places like alberta uh in ontario these
days people are pretty tired of being
shut down and they're and they're really
champing at the bit but also younger
people and disproportionately men are
actually women are more interested in
getting back out there
so i think what you're seeing is that uh
there is a coalition of the willing
developing in terms of trying uh trying
their hand at getting back to some form
of normal as for how we get there nearly
four in ten say vaccination is the most
effective way to bring the pandemic
under control just fourteen percent
think border closures or rapid tests in
the workplace will do the trick and
fewer than one in 10 say penalizing
those who won't get vaccinated will help
end the pandemic
well what we found is that people are
pretty supportive of a whole series of
things if somebody is a transgressor in
this on this front uh in order to be
able to deal with the the omicron
situation and in the pandemic in general
everything from mandatory vaccinations
through to taxing people but the
interesting thing is the numbers get
pretty narrow they start to get pretty
small um so when you talk about the
preference of maybe we should have
mandatory vaccines or we should for
example tax people it's more like no i
think maybe vaccines would be more
protective for people but what we're
finding on everything that we're looking
at is opinions that were pretty solid
even six weeks ago are starting to get a
lot more uh i would say loose
they are definitely
starting to break up a little bit the
consensus that we had previously about
what we should be doing in all of this
is not as strong as it once was